[Music]
so
[Music]
hey guys what's up welcome back to my
channel or if you're new here my name is
christian
and i live in my van full-time i've been
living in it for just over a year
and i've actually been on the road for
two and a half years i used to live in
my suv
before that so that's kind of what this
video is about
um one of the most common questions i
get is
how do you even get started with living
this kind of lifestyle
and so i thought i'd share a little bit
about my story
how i got from living an apartment to an
suv to a van
and also give you guys 10 tips steps i
guess you could call them
or just like advice on things that you
could consider if you are interested in
this lifestyle
all right so jumping right into how i
got here um
i was living in a two bedroom two bath
apartment in issaquah
washington which is just outside of
seattle the rent was super high
i was in a long-term long-distance
relationship of five years and
uh that was coming to an end so i was
pretty
upset devastated didn't know what to do
with my life
was reevaluating i was basically at a
crossroads trying to decide
you know like did i want to continue
paying rent did i want to maybe downsize
to a smaller apartment
um maybe just travel internationally for
a while or
maybe live on the road which is
something i'd always considered or even
just get a roommate you know there were
so many options i wasn't sure what to do
so i spent some time really thinking on
all my different options i
journaled i meditated i did this life
mapping exercise
i eventually realized that i'm not
getting any younger and if i want to try
van life like
just do it just try it if you hate it
you can always go back to living in an
apartment
so that's what i settled on and i soon
discovered
that bands were pretty expensive and not
all of them but
what i what i was hoping to buy was
pretty expensive and
i wasn't sure i wanted to commit to that
because i wasn't sure i would actually
like living on the road
so i decided to just live out of the
back of my suv which i had done in the
past for
the longest trip i had done was five
weeks i had my sleeping bag
and my camping blow up mattress in the
back seat and just a cooler
and it was fine like it wasn't super
comfortable but it totally
it worked so i knew it was possible it
was only supposed to be an experiment of
like three months to see if i liked it
but it was so chill i kept doing it for
14 months and after 14 months i realized
okay it's time to actually invest in a
full-time vehicle
like with a dedicated workspace so
that's when i invested in the van
and that's how i got here okay so here
are 10 things that i wish i had known
going into real life and that i'm hoping
will help you take some of the guesswork
out of the process
number one know your why why are you
drawn to this lifestyle
are you looking for more freedom do you
want more adventure
uh are you looking for a fresh start do
you want to save money maybe you're
trying to pay off student loans and you
don't want to throw away money on rent
are you looking to be location
independent
there's so many options here and i
personally chose this lifestyle for a
combination of those things
i was coming out of a long-term
relationship i really wanted a fresh
start
i'm an outdoor adventure photographer so
being location independent is super
beneficial
and i love the freedom of being on the
road
but knowing your why is really important
because
guys you will have hard days living on
the road
i haven't done a video really talking
about that yet but
there are some days when i absolutely
hate living in a vehicle
like no joke it can be really
challenging sometimes
but i remember my why i remember the
bigger picture i remember all the good
things that i love about it and
if you can come back on that and
stay grounded in that and be very clear
on your why then it will definitely help
you
persevere in this lifestyle number two
try it out
so if you can if you have the resources
i highly recommend
just renting a camper van from a rental
company
and doing like a two week road trip see
how it goes
you know like do you need a full
bathroom do you like a cooking setup do
you like the configuration
do you need a four by four these are all
things that are really helpful to work
out before you invest in a van
and just renting a camper van is a
really great way to do that
um another option if you have friends
that already are living on the road
maybe you could go do like a
extended camping trip with them and just
see how they live you can kind of get
some behind-the-scenes
advice or if you have a vehicle that you
can maybe
push the seats up or lay the seats down
if you have an suv
um you could just throw a camping
mattress and a sleeping bag and a pillow
in the back and go do a
week road trip and see if you like it
because there's a chance that you really
won't
there's a chance that you you won't like
being in a small space
you'll miss having a bathroom you'll
miss having a hot shower
maybe you can't work very well on your
laptop there's a lot of things to
consider
so i really highly recommend trying it
out first so let's say you tried it out
you did the road trip and you loved it
so now it's time to do your research one
of the most important things to start
with is
what kind of vehicle do you want to live
in so there's so many options here
do you want it to strictly be an
adventure rig do you want it to be a van
would it be a used van would it be a new
van do you want a 4x4
um do you want an rv or maybe a pickup
truck
with a pop-up tent does it need to have
a dedicated workspace
um do you need space for surfboards or
skateboards or mountain bikes will you
have a pet with you
will it be more than one person in the
van or
vehicle do you need a really intense
power setup do you need solar panels so
you can power
camera laptop so that you can work from
the road
once you decide what kind of vehicle you
want do you want to do the build
yourself
do you want to hire a company to do it
how much lead time do you need
to get a slot with that build company or
is it possible that you can make your
current vehicle work
like i did with my suv and as a side
note my friend
andrew kearns he's an amazing
photographer amazing videographer
he had um a land cruiser and as an
experiment he decided to live out of his
toyota prius and
he traveled the whole west coast in that
thing like he rocked it so
you have a lot a lot of options it
really comes down to your resources
what you're comfortable with and your
level of creativity
step four make a budget okay so you've
decided what kind of vehicle you want or
what you're working towards and
now you have a better idea of your
financial goals so
this is a good time to take inventory of
how much money you have
and where you can potentially cut
expenses
and lower your overhead so what i mean
by that is
your overall monthly expenses you want
to bring those down as much as possible
in order to save money
so maybe you can cancel unnecessary
subscriptions
maybe you can eat out a little bit less
maybe you can quit ordering lattes
maybe you stop shopping all together for
anything other than the essentials
um another option is to
kind of go through your things and
decide what you might want to sell
you can start listing smaller items on
craigslist facebook marketplace
um you could take them to a secondhand
thrift store
i started going through one room a day
about four to five weeks before i moved
out of my apartment
here's my closet so pretty much
i've been getting rid of bags and bags
of clothes
but this is like all the stuff that i'm
getting
well not all of it like half of this
i've decided to get rid of so far
and then i still need to go through this
stuff
and that half of dresser
drawers is stuff that's going to go this
half and keeping
and there's a lot of stuff down here but
i'm
really trying to break it down i would
make three piles
definitely get rid of maybe get rid of
and definitely keep
once i had started going through the
definitely get rid of pyle
and selling those things online i then
evaluated the
maybe keep pile by leaving that stuff in
a pile
and if after two to three weeks i hadn't
gone back to
retrieve something from that pile then
that to me was a good indicator that i
didn't really need it
already starting to accumulate stuff
that i don't want but this is all stuff
i'm
getting rid of i ended up selling those
things or
donating them and honestly like
going through my closet i donated i
don't even know
at least more than 10 garbage bags of
clothes and
that was pretty eye-opening just
realizing how much stuff i had
accumulated just clothing-wise i don't
even consider myself a big shopper but
yeah it's it's a pretty it can be a
daunting experience
um going down that
path of minimalism and it's not a
requirement for this lifestyle but it's
definitely helpful
um it's really nice to have everything
that you need and love
in your vehicle when you're traveling
storage unit is definitely an option
but yeah i think you'll find that having
fewer things makes the transition
easier outside of evaluating your
current financial situation
you might want to consider how you're
going to sustain your travels
how will you pay for gas how will you
pay for insurance
how you pay for food on the road so one
option is maybe you're just gonna work
and save up a lot of money and then
you go out and travel basically until
you run out of money and then you
go back to your job or your apartment
and save up again
another option is to maybe work remotely
for your employer
if that's a possibility or you could try
going freelance and starting your own
business and working for yourself on the
road which is what i do
and if you're interested in that i made
a video about it a couple weeks ago
you can check it out above in one of
these corners i'll link
it um but yeah finances are very very
important
and something that you don't want to be
blindsided by once you get on the road
number five plan for the basics how will
you
use the shower use the toilet and cook
your food
so these are three of the main hurdles
that you'll likely encounter when
transitioning to road life
there are a few different options here
and i actually have a whole episode on
toilet shower and laundry
up here if you want to check it out but
real quick some great options are just
to
especially during non-cova times get a
gym membership
that way you can shower exercise and use
the bathroom
you can just pay your monthly membership
another option is to just use truck
stops you can shower there
or you could use campgrounds uh just do
your research on which campgrounds allow
day you showers
there's also the option of a solar
shower or you could
consider having a full build in your
vehicle
you know there's an option for a fully
functioning toilet and a shower
inside your car there's rivers there's
lakes there's friends houses
airbnbs hotels all of these things are
options but it's important to consider
them ahead of time when it comes to
cooking it's pretty important that you
consider your current eating habits
and how living on the road will impact
them if you like a lot of fresh fruits
and vegetables
if you like to do a lot of cooking maybe
consider getting a fridge
or a cooler and a one burner stove
camp table there are a ton of options
check out the link below
to my real life essentials if you're
interested in my personal
recommendations
maintaining some form of familiarity and
routine in your new lifestyle will
really help you stay grounded
and will help you stay healthy number
six commit
so this is the stage where you would put
in your two weeks notice to your
employer or you would put in your notice
for your apartment lease
and basically commit to moving out and
moving on to the road
this is a step that you really shouldn't
take until
you have saved up enough money to move
forward with your plan this is also a
really good time to decide whether or
not you want to
rent a storage unit i rented a storage
unit for the first year and actually i
still have one now but it's much much
smaller than the one i started out with
um i now have a storage unit that's only
24 a month and it's a 4x5 unit and i
just have framed photos
and some heirlooms from my grandfather
in there so i could get rid of it but
it's so inexpensive i'm like why not
just keep it a storage unit is totally
optional but it can be really helpful if
you're
feeling a little overwhelmed by the
process of downsizing number seven
get vehicle insurance um ideally you'll
have insurance that covers your vehicle
your build and your belongings if
possible so i had kind of an interesting
journey with this
initially i had an suv and i just
maintained my renter's insurance that
would cover my belongings inside of my
suv
and then as a business owner i also have
to have separate business insurance for
my camera gear
so those things were covered separately
and then the vehicle itself was just
covered under normal insurance
when i got the the van that was a little
bit trickier for the first
year actually up until recently i was
paying for insurance that i found out
wasn't even valid
because um apparently
you know i paid like over two thousand
dollars and apparently it would have
been invalid because
i had a build and that basically
nullified the agreement
so what i ended up having to do was
getting my vehicle inspected
and approved as an rv and then
registering it
as an rv and then obtaining rv insurance
so my vehicle is registered as an rv
it's fully insured both the vehicle and
the build
and then i also have business insurance
for all of my camera gear
and personal belongings insurance so
that can get a little tricky and it's
honestly way easier to work out when you
still have a permanent address
so i would recommend doing that ahead of
time if possible that kind of leads into
number eight
which is figuring out how you're going
to receive
mail and how you're going to vote and
register
uh without an address so if you have
parents that live in the state that
you're living in or you can use that as
your residency
that's awesome if you have that option i
would recommend doing that alternatively
you could get a address at a p.o box
which is what i do
so that's where i receive my mail i just
have it forwarded to whatever
city i happen to be in if i need to do
so things like registering to vote
renewing your driver's license
registering your vehicle
those things are tricky like i won't lie
i've had some
gray areas where i've just been figuring
it out by trial and error
and i would highly recommend taking care
of those things before you move on to
the road when you still have an address
number nine have a plan a b
and maybe even a c before i moved into
an suv
i spent a lot of time pouring over
google maps
looking at ioverlander and
freecampsites.net
and blm land trying to determine where i
would potentially sleep once i moved out
of my apartment
and would it be in close proximity to
the gym so i could shower
a library a coffee shop so i could work
and have wi-fi
grocery stores there were a lot of
factors i had to consider
and my mind was just racing like where
am i gonna sleep how am i even gonna
make this work this is gonna be so weird
i actually spent the first night on
residential street
a block away from my apartment because
it's where i used to go running in the
morning and i was familiar with the area
and i knew people there so i just stayed
there and then after that
i was rumbling down forest roads and
sleeping out
on a mountain pass at first it was
really scary but then i eased into it it
was fine
my plan b was to rely pretty heavily on
friends
um to just go park in their driveway or
outside their house on the residential
street with their permission
plan c was basically to dip into my
savings and
get a hotel for one to two weeks to
reevaluate my situation and my life
and potentially go apartment hunting and
scrap the whole plan
and yeah get an apartment so thankfully
i adjusted to road life pretty well and
pretty quickly
but having all those plans in place
definitely gave me some peace of mind
number 10 last but not least have a
positive mindset
and a sense of humor if i've learned
anything from living on the road it's
that literally anything is possible
things rarely go as planned uh it's
something new every day
but the beauty of this lifestyle is that
i'm constantly being challenged i'm
constantly problem solving and
learning room and limitations lie and
also just
there i'm put into new and challenging
situations that force me to grow
all the time at the end of the day it's
really your perspective
and outlook about this lifestyle that
will make all the difference all right
so that's it
i am about to lose the light and someone
is parked next to me looking at me weird
because i
talking to myself in my car but um
i just wanted to throw those things out
there i really hope that they're helpful
and
i'd love to hear from you guys in the
comments about any additional advice you
might have or questions you might have
i always love hearing from you actually
if you guys want to catch up on a more
regular basis
head over to my instagram i post over
there pretty often
and that's where i usually hang out so
i'd love to see you over there
and until next time next video happy
[Music]
holidays
[Music]
you